hi my name is Liz McDonald and I'm a
space plasma physicist at NASA's Goddard
Space Flight Center so I study how the
beautiful dynamic Aurora's are born and
form and evolve and to do that I started
a project called Aurora Saurus people
all around the worlds can report the
Aurora that they see and that helps us
know where it is and what it's doing
the Sun gives us charged particles and
they impact the Earth's magnetosphere
which is our magnetic shield and the Sun
and presses the magnetosphere on the day
side when it's daylight and then
stretches it out into a long tail on the
night side where you see aurora this
magnetic field stretches and holds that
energy and periodically releases that
energy from hundreds of thousands of
miles away into the Earth's atmosphere
and that's where you get the lights of
the aurora
Steve is a rare unusual Aurora like
mystery in the night sky that was
spotted at lower latitudes than the
usual Aurora latitudes like Calgary
Alberta a very faint
purple ribbon was overhead in the sky
there and citizen scientists reported it
and we work together to understand more
and collect more traditional
observations about this ribbon the usual
Aurora rains down on the atmosphere from
space and creates light but Steve is a
really strong east to west flow and it
creates some light as it goes
I really can't choose just one there was
the Halloween storm of 2003 which was a
really big event that caused blood red
skies all over the US and I got to see
that from New Hampshire that was really
exciting
there was also Aurora that I've seen
from Fairbanks Alaska where my thesis
project was on a rocket to study that
Aurora and we were looking for big
whopping Aurora to find out the micro
physics of how that works it's really
hard to choose the Aurora is always
different